until first of all thank you everyone
for taking your time and becoming part
of lives every now this webinar is part
of partners and prosperities
multilingual webinar series where we are
trying to mobilize and spend awareness
about water management importance of
water conservation in half developed
techniques the water can be managed well
in agricultural my name is Krishna
Sharma and I am working as a coordinator
in policy impact with partners in
prosperity now I will just introduce you
to a project called web Peru which we
have been doing from last five years now
so underwater at this water productivity
project or web Pro we're essentially
trying to create a dream value chains
where the rice is produced using water
efficient farming techniques and the
protocol rice is exported to market
partners like cocoa
Mars and lt foods
anyone would like to know more about it
can speak to me personally going ahead
into the discussion I will just
introduce to his speakers first we have
this lovely equipments thank you so much
lucky for being part of developing now
she is what she is heading the global
sustainable sourcing part it Mars food
currently she has been working in areas
of project management as well as ask you
to kind in you tell we can still have
been noise in zebra girl yeah children
working in project management as well as
developing sustainable sourcing
strategies Thank You Loki for joining us
then dr. Kamal Bhatia has still not
joined us I cannot share same hands up
now moving to the next speaker we have
dr. su di giotto thank you so much for
being part of today's session leave the
senior scientist at IRI International
Rice Research Institute currently he is
leading the team of environmentally
sustainable methods in rice based system
then we have two mr. SP Sharma he is the
director at Central Water Commission
Ministry of Water Resources
they were development
under river development Ganga
rejuvenation Government of India and as
he said his news presentation based own
and not necessarily representing the
government or his department's opinions
who can go ahead with the discussion I'm
just
keep the lead to mr. Sharma now and we
will discuss the first question which is
what is the importance of water in
agriculture and how we can manage it
dr. Sharma over to you thank you good
afternoon everyone
answer to the question what is the
importance of water in agriculture I
would like to start from a little a
little with a little perspective at the
time of Independence our population was
only 33 rows 330 million now we have 1.3
billion and the agriculture issue was
such that at that time we were not
finding it possible to feed our own
people no we have done a lot of
management issues they have less they
have strictly because you see what was
correct at that time Green Revolution
now things have changed now we have
become population but we were then and
there are some serious quality issues
quantity issues of water no to the
question what is the importance of water
in agriculture now it is the chicken
tree but whatever we have whatever
resources whatever inputs we have owned
over at our disposal we must leverage
that we must erase them forever benefit
and what do we have here is water there
are some countries which are which are
quite water deficient for example in
Israel the per unit water fill ability
is less than and we are currently it is
approximately only
mr. Shah we can't show you I think
there's some technical issue hello yeah
yes yes so we can hear you not me okay
so what you see first coming back to the
question what is a big future
in agriculture water is very much
important because it is one of the few
resources which we have at our disposal
if we can leverage to feed of paper to
keep our country stable and prosperous
and and all the rest so we cannot
straightaway discount water and we
cannot also leave aside the issues of
environment about quality and all so
when we will really need is to have a
multi-faceted approach in my opinion my
personal opinion we cannot straightaway
neglect over supply supply side by side
results or splice side our answers and
either we can neglect our demand side
options we have to manage incident so I
think this is this is how I would like
to conclude is that we will have to
manage it by making a very fine a very
delicate balance between our demand side
solution and supply side solutions we
cannot straight away we remain dependent
upon one of them thank you thank you mr.
Sharma thank you so much for sharing
movies you will absolutely correct that
how there should be balanced well
maintained between how much with
demanding and how much reproduce in
against what resources are involved
because often what's the debate is that
I'll be really selling our crops of
- rice or really selling water so if you
manage a water well then of course I can
be looked after
thank you so much I could request you to
meet you video coming to the next
questions which is again one of the very
important question is understanding the
basics of what we're trying to do and
what is sustainable agriculture really
and right now to Delpy have with us
water and environment crew from
Uttarakhand who has done extensive work
in developing water management
techniques and you also have farmers in
Haryana we are trying to replicate this
model but before getting into them and
listening to definitions and views I
would request Lockett to present how he
was on this second question what is
technically go to sustainable
agriculture and why do we need it thank
you so much for the opportunity to share
more about what is sustainable
agriculture and and why do we need it
and maybe from the perspective of a
global big company and I would like to
share my screen that you need to give me
permission Sherman
okay thank you if you can see my screen
please let me know you can't see or you
cannot share if you can see it
let me know I can't scream yes you can
yeah okay excellent
okay so I work for Mars food to be part
of the big mass Inc company and we are
owners of the biggest global rice
friends and today I would like to share
a little bit background like why
sustainable rice becomes more and more
important in countries like Europe the
US but why it's also like Mars so first
of all as Marsh family and we find it
very important that we can make it
impacts so it's important we can drive
change we can also can so can everyone
go on mute please yeah I think yeah good
and driving impact is key and also we
identified within Mars our top products
and we can see that rice which is using
40% of the world's irrigation available
as business we shoot X upon what's a
reduction so that's something we do yeah
also why sustain rice is important it's
also important that's we can source
basmati it's growing it's growing in
Europe it's growing in the stage people
want to eat this fragrant rice so it's
import we have we can source from India
so it's important we can source quality
and health safety rice it's always
number one but we also think in the
future so also we want to source our
vast matting right so we need a
long-term supply well if water aquifers
are dropping
we need to act upon this we need to
think in the future for that reason we
are now partnering in the voucher
program in we really want safer water
stewardship approach and we also have
basmati rice in ten years time
even though we're very small of course
but for that reason we've partnering
with our suppliers but we also very
active in platforms as well like the
sustainable rice platform yeah another
aspects like why is sustainability
important it's it's important for own
and so shit's our own employees in Mars
and of course we also need to change it
into into growth in the business so for
instance but now you see it's very
important consumers they want to know
where is their food coming from it's
called a trust chain they want to know
where it's grown where it's coming from
and we do this for instance by putting
stories on the back of the back and we
show how much water is saved and by
farmers that grow yet great basmati rice
so having this in mind this is more like
saying why why it's so important that we
work on sustainability thinking about
the future yeah
then as a business we have set goals so
we said we can't do it on our own so we
member and take a leadership in the rice
platform and I think that's that's also
something we're now working on an India
we have plans maybe to set up a national
chapter about sustained rise platform we
also said we want to source rice from
the sustainer rice platform standard
that's one way how you can measure that
Farms are growing sustainable rice which
is key but we also say this is not
enough so we also say farmers they need
income otherwise it cannot join and
profit from any program so we need to
improve yields have meta access to
finance think also let's see how farmers
can sell their products like straw so we
need to work on income and today's topic
is about what I use so in high water
stress areas we need to reduce the water
use
and of course this is all linked to it
each other we can not only booze
[Music]
so we locate and there's some technical
issue I can't show you properly do it
also my partner switch in okay okay sure
did you hear my previous slides like the
goals properly yeah should I do it again
yes really nice okay yeah so as a
company we have set goals and first of
all we acknowledge we cannot do it on
our own
so for that reason we have joined the
sustain will rise platform both the
platform as well as adopting the rice
standards and we also really supporting
deaths in India we set up a national
chapter so that actors can be united in
yeah it's locating for sustainable rice
we in our goals we don't only see it as
SRP is the only one solution we also
work on income and what our use so that
means we need to work on better work
capital for rice growers increasing
yields lowering input costs as well we
see it we need to work on water
stewardship and all the goals of course
are interlinked together and something
reshoots and bets in in a similar
framework
could you hear me now yeah we do we are
with you okay okay good yeah we can't do
it on our own so we very active with a
lot of different partners we're having
who know this context very well and we
work closely with our suppliers we are
very advocating that we work through
Miller associations to really drive
sector change there may be the final
slides um what we always see that we
need to to think about the future long
term view so we need to think how can we
change the system so I would dream our
vision is Haryana shoots be an
attractive area that we can source high
quality basmati you know it's efficient
water in the future but it only starts
with if rice farmers they are
entrepreneurs they think as
enterpreneurs so grow rice and wheat in
a system and as well also farmers they
become stewards themselves of the
environments yeah they need this
well-functioning egg reserve system so
good governance should be there there
should be a good private sector
supporting them so what we do now we
work with our partners on having a goods
rice value chain we need to work on
adoption of climate smart practices and
we need to improve the enabling
environment so the policy parts yeah yep
I would stop here and then give it next
speaker yeah thank you okay in fact
injury is very important points but says
that farmers have to start working is
what rusty was really however my
question really is as a farmer as
someone who is directly working one team
when someone has to make a choice
they need to to understand the business
model so when you say the farmers have
to become entrepreneurs they also have
to find the utility of choosing what are
efficient techniques over the
conventional farming techniques will
fear anything - anything to add on that
but
yeah ISO agreed the business case should
be very clear so we always see the
income going hands and hands with water
so for instance we work now on a pre
finance model to get away the rabble
bank so that farmers can do for instance
lace telephony as a technique which also
will increase yields as well it will
reduce water as well so that's just one
example and as well we look at for
instance how we can use the byproducts
of rice for instance they sell the straw
so we always need to think through
longer term you have this model as well
yeah yeah absolutely correct
now I would like to open our slow to
four questions to the farmers were
sitting directly in Haryana in fact it
is important that you raised the point
of virgon at the facility six percent of
the exported rice is a load coming from
Indiana of the whole of the country so I
would request my colleague in taking
hurry on up ability to kindly open his
video and maybe we can hear from what
farmers have to say goodbye remove
cakana cheerio what is the importance of
local give me a minute and drink
translate and understand what Angie a
British attorney I think there's some
confusion but because it may be I want
to use the chat section so that we can
read the question from there
[Music]
a partner for general efficient
lucky and it's fishermen who spoke a
while back I would request any one of
you would know who would like to take
this question I think should magic us
anymore so now people would like to
address this question that how rainwater
can be used
actually I think Sudhir might be the
best one to answer because he's more
than water specialist of Irie
I can give my thoughts for collecting
rainwater I better leave it to the more
what a specialist yeah
not just a date if you would
we can't hear you
dr. Safir if you can maybe try to unmute
dr. Safir we continue I think there's
something
you
can you hear me now yeah I'm so sorry
yes yeah it's all technology um so thank
you very much and I'm very glad to see
you know all farmers and just just
inform them I'm also from Haryana so
that's very kind of good moment to see
people from my state the question which
has been asked and and performer I'm
sitting in Manila working for a
internationalisation for rice so the
question which has been asked I think
question is not how to you know usually
in water I'm looking at the chat box for
how to help in raising the groundwater
table which is kind of related question
that so there is a two-part first we
need to understand why groundwater is
going down so that's the first part and
the second part is how we can help so
there has been a lot of research done by
by universities by I see our Center on
how you can capture rainwater and how
that can be kind of linked to the
aquifer so the basically there has been
work done by different centers where at
the corner of your their field they kind
of installed a a bore well if you want
to call it and then that that act as a
water harvesting and the rainwater goes
directly to the keeper so the first part
is that by that whatever runoff is
happening that goes to your aquifer but
the more importantly thing is that the
the degree with which we can recharge
the groundwater that is still less than
the rate which we are extracting the
water so I think we need to also control
the extraction path that how we will
reduce our extraction so that the
depletion rate can be reduced so we feel
stop here thank you so much theater for
your sharing good news
with us and what you says it's it's very
important that house some techniques
which has to be introduced on ground
needs to be done and just move into the
next question which we have from
Rockland is the
what techniques can be adopted in Robbie
crop management will be independent
withdrawn water sources
so if any of us because would like to
answer this question of any doctors to
distance me you are this example or
something right and you know again yes
the question is not for rice that's for
OB season and it's very very interesting
that how we look from the system
perspective not only from from rice or
or abhi season there has been a lot of
work done in eastern India ass face in
eastern occur for days specie they are
I'm sure some of the farmers are
friendlier about briceida dries and then
not for rice but then they go for only
seeing Oh beat to kept up the residual
soil moisture with this small and be
serious about what we call window
operation you can reduce one irrigation
so there is a lot of work going on how
in eastern purposes basically we talk
about you know two to three degrees and
maximum to irrigation so if you can with
system thinking if you can capture the
residual moisture from rice starting
early with be dries with briceida dries
and then capturing residual moisture
going with that's not in efficient you
pee but in lot of work in punjab haryana
is going on using straw as a mulch so
with happy cereal lot of work is going
on in Haryana but that's not much input
for this in Uttar Pradesh I think there
is a lot of scope to go for early
planting of weight and using the regular
moisture of rice rather than wasting it
yeah thank you so much dr. su th by
telling you sir that how the byproducts
capacity Q's we have couple of questions
coming over and we would like us because
to ask them unfortunately we didn't
adopt ricotta with us in everything as
we would go forward and move in towards
the third question we would have these
answered questions answered in the next
session would close the question on
special for now
and then went to the third question of
today's presentation which is
how can technology be used in
improvising agricultural practices so
dr. Spier if you can enlighten us with
your views sure and I think this will
also help to address some of the
questions which are coming which are
indeed very interesting so when we talk
about how technology can be used in
provide aggregate share practices I
think we need to think about what we
mean by technologies people in you know
see technology from different
perspectives technology because we per
se kind of practice you know the tools
so the the recommendation
we kind of enabling tools to ease the
decision-making and technology can be
also in terms of catalyzing the adoption
of improved practices so it depends on
how we define that technology and I will
briefly talk about all three so when we
say about technology so people generally
say technology as something new a new
product motions are coming like drip
irrigation sand and documents and about
laser labeling so it depends on what is
our purpose is if our purpose is kind of
applying the less irrigation water then
we can go with the technology like laser
leveling so laser leveling will
basically what will it will help that
the amount of water which you applied
whether you apply like five centimeter
standing water ten centimeter whatever
you apply it to reach to that AMA level
the water quality require will be less
and I think at least in India there has
been sufficient adoption of laser
leveling a load in punjab haryana but
now it's speaking in eastern Uttar
Pradesh and Bihar alone and there is a
clear visible benefit of laser leveling
in terms of reducing the water and and
increasing the yield but then also if
there are other technology like if you
don't know if you want to reduce or you
want to increase the interval between
two irrigations
so how frequently you are applying
irrigation and then the technology like
alternate wetting and drying which is
again quite quite famous now in South
Asia that you you should have continuous
flooding you can dry your field to
certain level and there is a simple tool
to do that but then we also talked about
technology where you can reduce the
amount of water but you cannot reduce
the frequency so it's a frequent a flash
application of water that is brief so in
brief we have a technology where the
amount of water can be significantly
reduced but you need to apply it like
more or less daily
because it meet the idea for translating
demand so the point here is it depends
on what is the what are the challenges
in the reason
similarly when it's come to water it's
not only water per se it's also energy
in punjab and haryana it's most of the
pumps are on on electricity as we go
down in the eastern side there is a lot
of diesel operated pump and then it
comes to lydic how we can reduce the
energy footprints also and there are
different solutions easily in the in the
coastal regions there has been lot of
adoption of axial flow pump compared to
centrifugal pump where your energy put
pins can be significantly reduced
or there has been lot of projects now
started by by Government of India on
solar power so it's kind of green energy
using the green energy this is one one
lens using irrigation or energy the
other lens in terms of improving the
adaptation you know tapestry of the
farmer and in that one some of the
farmer asked about water harvesting so
basically if you if you can harvest the
water that improve your you know
capacity to adapt you know like if you
are going through drought so you can
apply supplemental irrigation and there
is a lot of work done on on clove
estimation method like dry seeded rice
but if if you can allow me to share the
screen pista if I can you hear me
okay thank you
then can you see my my screen I I think
you are mute so I'm assuming that you
are able to see yes yes i'm able to seem
sorry african to the screen yeah
oh okay can you see now not really we
can't see you scream you need to kick
twice like air and then you need to do a
lot more permission step
I think twice and then yeah
yet now we can
okay you can you can see so basically
what it went to different screen so not
sure this screen you are looking at all
right let's listen yeah okay let let
let's get it simple so what I mean here
that we generally as a as a researcher
we generally offer lot of technology to
farmers and sometimes made them
contribute we sometimes we are very much
ecology driven and in real sense I think
what farmers need help on is making a
decision that what what are the best way
to make that decision what technology
can be picked and technology know is not
only about like following laser leveling
or not the decision is whether laser
leveling is required or not or after how
many years later learning is required
whether for your system I repeat is a
good option so maybe you are getting in
a frame you you target the system game
so there is a lot of work which is
required in terms of helping farmer in
decision making and now he was talking
about enabling environment and this is
similar to that one that where you
invest on building the capacity of the
system that is also with policy lens but
then now there are lot of ICT IOT based
tool which are very powerful in terms of
picking the right at newly which are
suitable for a particular reason farmers
in haryana their questions are different
than farmers in purple bays and farmers
in bihar so we cannot fit one size to
all and it's very very important that we
we use now the tools in terms of leaving
it with farmers I have been telling that
this is best for you leaving with them
to pick what is best for them because
they are the kind of best people to
understand the regular environment
understand their challenge and I think
what we can do is helping them in terms
of exploring the cafeteria of
technologies and and telling them the
pros and cons of different technologies
and and then these
can also help to catalyze the chains
which are required you can see that it's
there is one more slide which is
basically saying that we have
technologies but and we know the
stakeholder need but technology them
generally doesn't reach to the
stakeholders and that's the gap which we
need to fill that how how what kind of
now tools we can develop so that we can
reach add metal near to farmers I'll
stop here for now all right thank you so
much dr. Sudhir you're absolutely
correct in how we have been we do need
to enable these farmers to make it
informed choice and it and this enabling
factor who could have multiple values
one could be to give them the
appropriate information of whatever kind
of facility is available the kind of
videos or just share the screen or even
at the part of the government of what in
terms of what kind of initiatives in the
schemes are available for example
subsidies we have been involved in this
part of enabling farmers by training
them in various kinds of for a few water
efficient farming techniques and one of
which was water stewardship which was
being done under our water productivity
project so Joanna from our Auckland
office is connected to us and we have
three and four charities who were the
community persons working directly with
the farmers on how they developed and
also made sure that the farmers know
what they're doing and also explaining
them that how they can implement these
shrim last many years so maybe we could
hear her views and also head directly
from some of our jockeys
if you would allow me
just like a New Year's yes yes I would
like to hear Lennon just before getting
into that we're really glad that we have
apples from Pakistan and joining us
Bonita Bernard who are implementing the
virtual productivity project in Pakistan
which we have been doing in India so to
hear their views as well something and
yeah drugs man yes yep just life you
know can tell us about the experience of
working within the community and
nibbling the families and how Joseph
Lee's worked directly on what using
technologies and see all these
technologies have been demonstrated in
the field areas terrain is a ruby and
intercropping jilsuk he told was to
monitor the level of water and
irrigation during the past three years
and as the result we heard analyzed in
twenty five percent of water saving has
been twenty three to twenty five percent
water saving has been experienced to
these practices so genifique is this
water monitoring part they are created
water and environment groups in the
region of many tablets chips that our
project is pain is going on so the water
and environment meaning purpose is to
monitor and mean it mainly in the water
infrastructure and where community
members towards what reusable water
tunes yeah
in fact for everyone we have been
successfully able to mobilize country in
four thousand five
that farmers in a project and how this
word of mouth works among the farmers
community is that when someone village
or say a particular block is being
trained or being told about what is
happening it's it's slowly a rights
among the other farmers and again what
love who is talking about that if you
present them with a lucrative business
model which is that if they're producing
water-efficient or maybe as artists and
there's rice that can be easily exported
and given at a good price if I'm correct
okay yes absolutely
well since we're done with the what the
speakers has to say will be still one
question left I would request a wrap low
fat burn and Pakistan if they would want
to then there's online questions as well
like what are the low-cost technology
that can be adopted by farmers without
even increasing costs yeah yeah if you
would like to go ahead and do answers
because here and then went right into
questions
so alia joined us from Pakistan I like a
new heroes
he's Amanda without proper dress I think
the sub Technicolor role in the country
anyway let's go ahead and
take answers one questions one-by-one
so can drip irrigation system they using
particle duration
and that's something a reoccurring
question and I think dr. Sudhir you
would like to give your opinion
um so yes definitely there has been lot
of work done of using drip you know in
rice I'm familiar the work was done in
Haryana and canal work was done in Modi
Purim also work was done however there
is another question that can be it's
kind of safe water without additional
investment you know so that's kind of
the scenario that when it comes to the
paddy cultivation the initial investment
with the drip and the technology is
still kind of settling among speaking
from my perspective that from its it's
definitely there is a research done but
for adoption of farmer it's still bit
expensive so that now the many many
private companies are working on low
post drip irrigation system but the the
adoption for drip is still low in very
low in in rice because they they don't
see kind of the output against the
investment so the marginal quote is very
high
while in lot of rain fed area in Uttar
Pradesh we have followed from there and
they have started to use this low post
drip irrigation in the dry season for
growing vegetables and they like it's
it's very high profitable system so it
all depends on the technologies
excellent
but when farmer PK technology it's not
only from technology perspective they
look it from different lens so and that
this depends on the whole system that
what kind of system you have and then
whether drip is a potential choice for
you alone yeah yeah of course in fact
they have been we have in the project
which will be working in Haryana have
been discussions whether we put
implement drip irrigation in paddy
cultivation and see can work that but
we're also considering the factor that
it has been done before but in different
kinds of atmosphere and also the soil
and I am skeptical about if the kind of
soil will make any difference because
the Illyria's will be different in in
comparison to mummy beef because like
Haryana so no they
so the it depends on there are two
different things one is when you
schedule irrigation and how you
scheduling is and whether you use drip
or you use flood that is how when is
interval and when will take care of soil
type so when in deep irrigation you
consider the evapotranspiration so you
have pressure is from the soil
transmission is on the plants so you
consider that one and you schedule by
irrigation but my my simple kind of
question or suggestion to farmers and
I'm thinking more like a farmers being
on up in Haryana like if farmers are at
least some progressive farmer are
started to think for for drip so which
means they are only thinking to dry
their fatty fill if if they can dry they
paddy field with surface irrigation they
can save a lot I'm not saying that you
know rape is good it can further
increase the saving but in terms of what
low-hanging opportunity which we have
with us is saving this water which we
are pumping from the ground water and
that is really really kind of alarming
the situation in punjab and haryana
first i think the big message is that if
they believed rupees good thats mean
rice can be grown and like other serious
like wheat so they can change it in
their surface irrigation system also and
then it's a step change then they can
adopt really big at later states yeah
yeah thank you dr. Sudhir of course what
you said definitely can be done so this
question which is a bit convoluted with
just you giving the gist is really that
what are the policy level initiatives
that can guide water stewardship
at a multi-level so it can be implement
so really what the question is trying to
understand is what kind of policy change
is required when water stewardship can
be implemented very well in all like in
regional setting in a state level
setting or say a national and even
international setting if lauki would
like to comment and maybe later doctor
City it would give his own opinion on it
yeah I'm I'm not Leslie the expert of
course in the in the policy parts
because this is I think maybe Sharma you
even might be yourself able to answer of
course like having improved policies
having incentives for rice growers is
essential so I spoke really about the
enabling environments what we see for
instance in other regions where the
government might have incentives for
collecting rainwater for providing
subsidies for using drip irrigation
that's one rule then of course also
policies in place where maybe there
might be a restriction of farmers using
water in Pakistan there debates whether
actually water should be paid by farmers
so it just depends on the context of
course yeah yeah but says you're someone
who can speak for the market I would
like to know your views and what
capacity markets can influence the
policy what kind of kind of change can
be done from your end
for example the points raised before was
how they can increase price and we are
working with SRP or something yeah so if
we talk about premiums as March we need
high quality basmati so we always pay
for a quality premium in farmers so that
already helps farmers to increase their
income then we of course we work with
our suppliers who have acronym is to
provide coaching to farmers so every two
weeks they will receive guidance how to
better grow the rice which also
increased yields by 15% of course we
also work on improving let's say better
markets so market route to markets
transport lowering transport costs and
then of course if they grow SFP rice we
we won't expect we pay a premium I do in
organics which we would rather see by
all the interventions that farms can
benefits by growing rice in a more
sustainable way yeah Annie
I can add and to allow in terms of
incentivize farmers for kind of climate
smart practices one of the one of the
debate which is going on is on providing
incentives to farmers for carbon correct
which has been already started in
investing word but in a CIT is not
introduced and there has been and this
is a macro level at at country level and
country whole different kind of funds
the one is which we they can access his
Green Climate Fund which can be Kentucky
laid down for to provide a you know
additional incentive for reducing the
water footprint and and carbon footprint
so as you know that rice is one of the
major source of methane emission so it
can be sometime direct some time
indirect so if they they use the water
efficiently they not only save water but
they also reduce the global global
warming potential so people of Haryana
know that what is happening in the
hlne in inventory you know so there is
a lot of work need to be done in terms
of how we we do how we improve the egg
practices but more importantly what what
is the pull mechanism and that I think
we need to think out of the box to
incentivize farmers through premium rice
coding price or through these new
incentive mechanism of carbon footprints
yeah yeah thank you so much dr. city for
adding your reviews and of course
methane emissions was a very important
side effects of brown rice and it we are
contributing towards not generating that
kind of emission into theaters we're
considering Delhi is the UM India's
pollution level that will be put into
one station in terms of the ecological
their contribution from the farmers end
but the Diskin solid always comes to me
as it moves from us from you know
putting my faith in a farmers show is
that why is there everything Bertrand oh
honey why do I have to need
to make all the difficult choices
because essentially what matters to me
is growing and just getting the better
price so if you would like to comment on
that I will now give you anything I
would not say it's always about the
price it's more what we say the more
crop per acre so productivity that
that's a clicky one also what we see a
lot in the system that a lot of rice
growers are dependent on a middleman to
have loans to need to pre finance their
input costs and that actually is a huge
burden on the on the final net income
from rice so we now might be working
more on pre finance which can reduce 20%
of their financial of their input costs
which are spent by paying fourteen to
twenty four percent of Texas so rather
just having the premium discussions I
would rather go in in these roots
thinking about refinancing dependency or
middlemen and whether we can also play a
role in this and I came to here because
I know it's very challenging as a full
of rice growers also needs middlemen as
their provide a bank not only for
agriculture but also for education and
other other let's say loans as well yeah
thank you okay adding to that I think
one of the participants with us as dr.
sedative saying was directed at I CIT
International Organization for
irrigation and drainage maybe he would
he would be an expert person to add
comments on how changes can be done at a
policy level doctor sedative if you
would like to add a special
if you would unmute yourself you can't
hear you
yes
you
what does that I can't hear you
yeah maybe I don't want to spoil the
party but this morning I was reading the
newspaper and interestingly there is a
study by a Policy Research Institute
which says that the crab burning in
Haryana Punjab alone costs us dollar 30
billions per year to the Indian economy
and I don't know I think that's a very
death that's a number which is very
close to the total agricultural exports
of India basically the punjab haryana
reason is not the agro-ecological jewel
for rice farming and it was introduced
because of the Bhakra Nangal then then
which provided sufficient water so
people says to the cash crops like the
basmati rice which is an export
commodity so maybe I had been studying
this problem for last 2-3 years and it
seems that Punjab and Haryana received
only 40 percent of the monsoon rain that
the West Bengal and the northeastern
part of India which are more suitable
for rice farming we see and I don't see
any research which gives a direction
that how we can grow federal trials like
basmati in the northeast parts of India
which state ships adequate once on the
info and in the Punjab Haryana region
but I am NOT against technology I mean
I'm an engineer myself and drape and all
these things can always make the water
use efficiency much higher but should we
not be practicing something something
which is ecologically or ecologically
sustainable that's that's my question to
the experts here of course there is a
need for into improving the economy of
farmers
improving their income but are there
other ways which we
should we should think about or there
are other options policy options which
can incentivize the shift in farming
practices making it more ecologically
sustainable in the longer yes thank you
dr. Sade for sharing your views I know
you're short of time but we have two
questions which are still left
unanswered if you could keep it on the
table now
the first one is how can white water
stewardship affect the quality and
quantity of daily culture to do so
essentially what is the benefit of what
stewardship so if you would like to heal
electricity
so basically when we are seeing about
whenever we talk about water saving
people sometimes take it as like we are
cutting off significantly it's there is
a difference between water requirement
of krob versus water applied to the crew
and they're basically it's all about the
intelligence about like how much water
need to be applied I I want to quickly
also make the point about what Sade was
saying that I also believe in terms of
the whole window operation thinking
about how you can make decision based on
your ideological condition and based on
your water ability so you are the some
of the like I know the verbage Mars food
is doing the attach managing practices
that the climate smart practices which
will not affect your quantity that may
improve your quality but David that will
definitely not affect your quality so
it's win-win situation which basically
we are talking here rather than reducing
quantity and quality yeah absolutely
it makes also a lot of sense because it
we are conserving water and managing
water not only are we making an
ecologically better choice between
so in terms of the market making you
know a better repository as raised by
Lao K that how premium is also being
paid by companies and for that matter I
know that Mars has been paying premiums
LT Foods and other market features also
paying premium for better maintained
rice just this last question which is
being left unanswered is the what is
what are the low cost technologies that
can be adopted by farmers without
increasing cost
um
again I think it depends on I always go
back to that what are the what are the
conditions rather than saying that this
technology can be can fit very well to
you we have seen a very very high impact
and again today was talking about this
HP study and another if we study in
eastern refer this fear the the early
planting of wheat followed by ugly
planting of so early planting a price
followed by early planting of beef was
able to make significant change in water
productivity because they were using
rain efficiently so it's not always that
you need to try a new rotate it's
sometime it's the decisions which you
make around the production system there
are series of technologies which which
can can be adopted but again I would
come back to that it all depends on what
are the conditions and accordingly we
can we can suggest the appropriate
technologies
thank you so much dr. city for sharing
your time and your use with us I think
we just ending the very nice already 332
and Tetris of internet problem P also
don't have a love cake would be does as
of now so first of all I would like to
thank everyone for sharing their views
and the participants from red yellow
rock and Pakistan and different parts of
the country